हुआ था नमस्कार आप सभी का स्वागत है जर्मन
सीखिए हिंदी में के अगले एपिसोड थे इस बार
हम सीखेंगे दो सबसे महत्वपूर्ण जर्मन व
आपन और जाएंगे और हम सीखेंगे कि अपने
इंट्रोडक्शन जर्मन में कैसे ले लीजिए तो
चाहिए करते हैं शुरू
जब तुम किसी भी भाषा में जर्मन ही नहीं
किसी भी भाषा में दो वक्त सबसे इंपोर्टेंट
है आपन और जॉइन इंग्लिश में टू हैव और टू
बी सी डी हिंदी में बोल सकते हो मेरे पास
कुछ है और मैं कुछ तो हूं हम बहुत प्यार
इन वर्ग का यूज करते हैं और यह जो वर्ग है
दोनों यह जर्मन में irregular भर से व्हाट
यू मीन बाय रेगुलर तो अगर आपने अब हमारा
पहला पार्ट अगर देखा होगा तो इसमें हमने
सीटें कि छोटे-छोटे सेंटेंस कैसे बनाने और
उसमें हमने वर्क पंक्चुएशन सिखा इस प्रेम
का दूध तनु संयंत्र इन कर मतलब अगर मैं
पीता हूं तो इसके बाद भी लगा था तुम पीते
हो दो के लिए टेस्टी लगाना तो यह है हमारा
रूल स्क्रीन का दूध फ्रेंड्स विवाद रिंकल
कि यह तो जो वर्ग है वह रूल को फॉलो नहीं
करते तो फिर यह कैसे वर्क होते हैं यह अब
हम देखेंगे तो सबसे पहले हम हवन को लेंगे
यह थोड़ा सा आसान है
अच्छा तो चलो देखते हैं
कि मेरे पास कुछ है इस सांप तुम्हारे पास
कुछ है दो हाथ
कि उनके बहुत ही चीप रेट है समथिंग ऐलेडी
हाथ
कि हमारे पास कुछ है यह हाफ बंद तुम दोनों
के पास कुछ हाथ उन लोगों के पास कुछ हां
बहुत सिंपल है इस हां बोल दो हाथ पैर जी
हां
आधावन जो एग्जाम लेते हैं तो आपको इजी हो
जाएगा का यह मेरे पास और है इस हाथों और
वह हमारे पास मर्सिडीज है वीडियो हवन
मर्सिडीज बहुत सिंपल है कुछ भी बड़ी बात
नहीं है इसके बाद आएगा तो भी यह फिर
जाएंगे किसी भी भाषा का सबसे इंपोर्टेंट
वर्ड होता है टू बी क्यों क्योंकि आप उससे
बहुत सारे सेंटेंस बना सकते हो फॉर
एग्जांपल आई एम केदार आयल स्टूडेंट लाइन
thirty-six ईयर्स ओल्ड यह सारी चीजें आप
सिर्फ ऐड करके या फिर टू बी करके बना सकते
मैं इंग्लिश में टू बी अवर होता है आपको
पता होगा टू बी अवर नॉट टू बी इज द
क्वेश्चन पर अगर आप देखोगे कि उसका मूल
रूप या इंफिनिटी वॉर रूम पैक टू बी पर
इंग्लिश में वह चलता है आए युवक कृषि इट
इज विहार उद्देश्य वैसे ही जब में यह
कंपलीटली रेगुलर उसका जो के रूप में चलता
कैसे आई एम इस दिन यूअर धूप इस चीजी एग
विहार व वह दोनों साइड और विजेंद्र
है मतलब फिर से हम एक बार करते हैं इस
बिंदु बेस्ट रजिस्टर वीर व एयर रायड्स इन
हम हर चीज खा लेते हैं तो आपको इजी हो
जाएगा मैं स्टुडेंट हूं इस बीच स्टूडेंट
स्टूडेंट हो दूर बेस्ट स्टूडेंट स्टूडेंट
स्टूडेंट हम सब स्टूडेंट स्टूडेंट और वह
सब स्टूडेंट है
10 सिंपल है न कुछ बड़ी बात नहीं है अब
बोलोगे इतने सारे जेवर हमने देखिए बिग
बेस्ट सीन हम कैसे याद रखेंगे अच्छी बात
यह है कि हम day-to-day लाइफ में सबसे
ज्यादा इसी वर्ग को यूज करते हैं तो जितनी
आप बात करोगे उतना डिविलियर्स जाऊंगी ओके
अभी एक छोटी सी बात यहां पर ही आई इसलिए
मैं आपको बताता हूं जर्मन में आप बहुत
इंटरेस्टिंग चीज है जर्मन में अगर आप
लड़के हो तो आप स्टूडेंट है और अगर आप
लड़की हो तो आप स्टूडेंट इन आई एन लग जाता
है अगर आप इंजीनियर लड़के हो तो आप इन्हें
9 एयर अगर आप इंजीनियर लड़की हो तो इंडियन
ऑयल रिमूव हो
है इतना ही नहीं अगर आप फ्रेंड ऊपर लड़के
हो तो फ्रंट हो अगर आप लड़की हो और फ्रेंड
हो तो फॉर ए डे इन थे लाइफ मजे की पर
है तो भी इसका यूज करके अभी हमने क्या
कैसी था कोई क्लीयर वॉइस करते हमने दो
वर्ग सीखें हां बंद और जाएंगे हां बंद
मतलब मेरे पास कुछ है तो है वह जाए मतलब
टू बी मैं कुछ हूं हवन करके चलता है इस
हां पर दो हाथ एनएससी हॉट वीरप्पन यह फेस
जी हां बंद साइन कैसे चलता है इस दिन
बेस्ट ड्रेसेस अभी इसका यूज करके हम अपनी
इंट्रोडक्शन दे रखे हैं ओके आज हम इडली
अपने इंट्रोडक्शन में सीखेंगे
कि मैं अपने इंट्रोडक्शन दूंगा आप क्या
करूं जब मैं अपना इंट्रोडक्शन दो राव अपने
निरीक्षक लिख लो और फिर आपके भूलने की
कोशिश करो या फिर कमेंट में लिखो मैं आपको
करेक्ट भी करके दूंगा ठीक है तो मैं एकदम
शांति से अपने पड़ोसियों बताता हूं आप
अपनी डिक्शनरी बोलो ठीक है
कि मैं किरदार हूं इस बिल के दांत
है कि मैं इचलकरंजी से आता हूं
कि इस काम आएगा उस इचलकरंजी रबड़ प्लीज
कि मैं यूनिक में रहता हूं जिसको जर्मन
में हुए शामिल
कि इस वरना इन 69
कि मैं इंजीनियर फिश ब्रीडिंग रॉयल के और
कौन-कौन सी भाषा बोलता हूं मैं मराठी
हिंदी इंग्लिश और जर्मन मिलता हूं तो मैं
बोलूंगा इस स्पेशल हिंदी मराठी इंग्लिश
ढूंढ और ऑयल मतलब चैनल और मैं छत्तीसगढ़
कम
हु इस विन बैक सुन राइजिंग यार उठ यार
मतलब हेयर आर्ट मतलब ओल्ड इस बिन जग सुन
राइजिंग यार अलार्म समझ में शांति से अपनी
प्रोडक्शन देता हूं आप मेरे साथ अपने
इंट्रोडक्शन देने की कोई चीज है
हु इस विन के अलावा इश्क उमर आहट से चलकर
जी
कि इस वह लाइन उने
हु इस विन इंडिया 91 पर स्पेशल हिंदी
मराठी इंग्लिश उन्माद और इस बिल से इस अंश
यार अलग-अल
ए सिंपल है न आप दो-तीन बार प्रैक्टिस करो
आपको भी अपना इंट्रोडक्शन दे दिया आएगी तो
इस पाठ में हमने दो सबसे इंपोर्टेंट वर्ग
सीखे जर्मन की 52 और जाएंगी छोटा सा
एक्सांपल मेरे पास पिज़्ज़ा है इस खबर पीस
द मैच स्टूडेंट हूं इस बीच स्टूडेंट और
उसका यूज करके हमने अपनी इंट्रोडक्शन दे
किसी मुझे आशा है कि आपको यह पार्ट अच्छा
लगा हो नेक्स्ट पार्ट में हम जर्मन
ग्रीटिंग सीखेंगे हाय कैसे करेंगे बाय
कैसे करेंगे इस सॉरी थैंक्यू कैसे बोलेंगे
यह नेक्स्ट पार्टनर सीखेंगे तो मिलते हैं
नेक्स्ट पार्टनर धन्यवाद